[Music]
5 14 here on your friday morning we had
a great example of busy people who might
not have a ton of time to help out but
work hard to sandwich
giving into their already
jammed schedules
last week jeannie clayton an english and
leadership teacher at tarkanian middle
school helped lead dozens of students to
beat their own record of
peanut butter and jelly sandwiches for
the homeless
kids from tarkanian's national junior
honor society were joined on the project
in a giant zoom call with kids from
gundersen middle school frees elementary
and desert oasis high school they put
notes of positivity on each of 2815
sandwich bags
and after the marathon of munch making
there was a convoy to the care complex
in the heart of the homeless corridor
north of downtown las vegas congrats to
miss clayton and everybody involved in
the sandwich project and if you're
looking for the good news about students
in the nation's fifth largest school
district check this out there's a
facebook hashtag positively ccsd some
great stories there if you know
something that's cool at school let us
know cool it's cool is under the
community tab on eight newsnow dot com
or just send us an email cool at school
at eightnewsnow.com how cool is that
that's a lot of peanut butter and jelly
it sure is but it was spread out so to
speak amongst four different schools
they're in the southwest valley oh
that's fantastically great crunchy or
creamy it might have been both okay and
i don't know whether it was grape or
strawberry or orange marmalade or
whatever but the fact that it happened
is fantastic yes and notes of positivity
like you got this or you know you're
great yeah and that just takes even more
time because you're writing it out i
love it yeah teamwork teamwork makes the
dream work